we continue our state of the union
coverage with vice president kamala
harris madam vice president good morning
good to see you this morning good
morning good morning good to see you
again let's get right into the speech it
was a tale of two speeches last night we
had to start with foreign policy for
obvious reasons because of what's going
on in ukraine ukrainian president
zielinski is asking the west for more
support and last night president biden
said putin has no idea what is coming i
realize you can't share with us
administration secrets but is there
another card to play here
well first of all i think the president
did an outstanding job of articulating
what is at stake
and what is at stake is that ukraine
is an independent nation and we as as
the united states of america will stand
uh for its sovereignty and its
territorial integrity the president
outlined the extraordinary work that we
have been doing with our allies to bring
these nations together in particular the
european union and our nato allies to
stand in solidarity in support of
ukraine in fact just yesterday
most recently i spoke with world leaders
including the prime ministers of poland
of latvia estonia lithuania and romania
talking about the work that we have done
as the united states to bring people
together on a variety of issues that
relate to sanctions which are some of
the most severe that we've ever seen but
also the work that we are doing to
remain committed to a unified response
to what is happening in terms of
russia's aggression i hear you on that
but those images are heartbreaking to
watch we see innocent civilians being
killed we see children being killed and
the administration has made it clear
there will be no boots on the ground
what will it take will anything change
that will we stand by and watch innocent
people continue to be killed here
well gail you're absolutely right it's
heart-wrenching it's heartbreaking
they're they're the image of a missile
that that struck just right next to a
children's playground
the ukrainians who are as civilians
taking up defense of their nation out of
pride and also an understanding of what
is at stake in terms of their vitality
and their independence so it is
heart-wrenching to be sure but i will
tell you the president is clear we are
clear we are not going to put u.s troops
in ukraine to fight the russians not on
the ground and not in the air but we are
going to continue working with our
allies to one
defend every inch of territory as it
relates to nato territory but also what
we will continue to do with the billions
of dollars of humanitarian security and
and military assistance that we have
been providing ukraine there is so much
at stake and each day we re-evaluate and
do more to make sure that we are
supporting the ukrainian people and
president zlansky who i met with just
about a week ago in munich he has shown
extraordinary courage and um in this
moment i think he has been an
inspiration to all of us
let's switch to some of the domestic
issues that were raised last night you
know there
the president made a point of saying
fund the police he got applause it seems
from both sides of the aisle on that but
there was very little mention very
little mention of voter voting rights
does this mean that that issue is on the
back burner for the administration at
this point in time
the president has been very clear he was
clear again last night in in in front of
the members of the united states
congress they must pass the john lewis
voting rights advancement act and the
freedom to vote act the president has
said over and over again and we have
made very clear that this is about
protecting america's democracy against
those various states in particular
and state legislators and governors who
are in a full-on assault on the right of
every american who is eligible to
actually be able to vote i've been
traveling the country in fact later
today i'll be in north carolina and what
we are saying about laws that are being
passed that would make it illegal to
give somebody who's standing in line to
vote food and water is outrageous laws
that are being passed that make it more
difficult for people to to drop their
ballot off in a drop box okay let's talk
about high priorities when it comes to
inflation the new cbs poll found 70
percent of americans disapprove of the
administration's handling of inflation
what do you say to those people who say
gas prices are just too high i can't get
peanut butter everything cost more
what are you going to do
listen people are struggling especially
working people in terms of the
price of gas and food and and the the
reasons include what we need to do to
address what happened through through
the pandemic in terms of supply chain
issues which was a reduction of the
availability of goods and so the prices
went up we also need to deal with one of
the biggest issues which is the cost of
living it's too expensive for working
families and so that's why we have been
clear the president said last night
let's bring down the cost of child care
so that working families don't pay more
than seven percent of their income in
child care how do you do that well what
we do is we pass the legislation that we
have been pushing which will bring down
these costs and make living more
affordable for working people that needs
to happen in addition to what we will
continue to do to grow our economy as
the president said last night we have
seen the largest amount of growth of our
economy in 40 years we've seen in the
last year
and that is a statement about the the
integrity of the policies that we are
implementing but it's also a statement
about the resilience of the american
people to rise to this moment through
very difficult times in particular
around the pandemic thank you very much
madam vice president i know you got it
right good to be with you thank you